us sends more missile defense systems to
Middle East I love this headline because
they don't want to actually uh give you
the headline that explains we're about
to go to World War I the latest
deployment is in response to Growing
threats from Iran and its allies in the
region President Biden has warned Iran
to not join the war against Hamas why
would Iran join a war against Hamas see
the New York Times phrases these things
in very interesting ways so they're
sending a Thad
battery which is uh um I don't know if
they what it stands for it's uh
something altitude aerial defense or
something like this I forgot what the
first one is you sending Thad battery
and additional Patriot battalions to its
most powerful weapons against missiles
to the region in a statement Sunday blah
blah blah they're going to be sending a
lot more and we have this from Bloomberg
us vows to hold Iran responsible for
attacks on troops in mid East Pentagon
spokesman places blame even without a
direct order us is moving more forces
weapons and ships to the region so we
already had
19,000 we're moving up to 21,000 active
Personnel in the region I think six uh
well Washington Post reported 4,000
Marines and sailors with 2,000 troops I
guess more Marines so I don't know what
how many of those individuals are
specifically for uh uh ground combat
says the us ramed up his rhor toward
Iran saying it would hold Tran
accountable for drone and Rocket attacks
on US troops by its proxies in the
Middle East even as Washington tries to
avert a r wider Regional War they keep
saying that does is Washington actually
trying to avert anything I don't think
so like Nikki Haley that are just you
know just they just want us to go to war
they've got Ron in their closet and we
shouldn't be involved at all you know
Biden shouldn't be making statements it
and and really any Republican who calls
himself America First should not be
advocating for any action whatsoever in
the Middle East we have our own problems
here we don't need to worry about abroad
uh we've got veterans killing themselves
I think it's 16 a day young men killing
themselves at as astronomical rates more
than any other demographic in the
country we don't need to be over there
and especially in a situation where
you've got two sides of it where both
are committing atrocity and I think most
people just want peace but even if you
say you want peace if you say you want a
ceasefire folks like Ben Shapiro will
say that you're a pro terrorist and so
it's really unfortunate and uh if you're
going to be America First you cannot be
Pro involvement in the Middle East at
all so that is terminal high altitude
area defense formerly known as theater
high altitude area defense so that's
what it stands for I I remember when I
was in South Korea they had a bunch of
people protesting saying no Thad and the
argument was that the US was going to
deploy the Thad system in to be able to
respond to North Korea North Korean
ballistic missile attacks but as as I
mentioned in the earlier segment many
journalists are saying Hezbollah and
Hamas don't have this so the US is just
gearing up for war with Iran I think a
lot of these news stories a lot of them
are
intentionally they're they're seeding
they're a little bit of spice in the
news to be like get you used to it war
with Iran War with Iran that way when
something something happens cuz now
we've got conversations about sleeper
cells Hamas sleeper cells in the United
States the US is trying to connect Hamas
to Iran as much as they can for sure
because of what just happened in Israel
now we've got reports Kevin McCarthy
Ronda santis have been warning about
this they're saying Hamas has sent
sleeper cells to the Su Southern border
the next thing that happens is some kind
of false flag or just an outright attack
from Hamas and then they say see that
was a run yeah I think ultimately that
is the direction I also think it's very
difficult for the American people to
keep up with all of the moving Parts
there are so many moving Parts there so
many moving parts and they they share a
complicated intertwined Regional history
that we just are blind to in a lot of
ways we don't really know it we don't
know that history we know you well but
what's interesting though and this is
some research I was doing uh over the
weekend actually and last week um the
history that we know of Israel in the
Middle East is given to us primarily and
given to our students by textbooks and
those textbooks were were um created
most of them after 9/11 at this point
and they were heavily influenced by like
the center for Islamic education that
talked to the Publishers and the
textbook companies and made sure to have
very positive views of Islam and very
negative views of Judaism and
Christianity so when you see all of
these high school students staging
walkouts of like you know saying like uh
you know free Palestine and like stand
with Gaza and all Stu they have been
taught that in their history classrooms
that is what they have learned directly
and they have learned that directly um
because that's you know that's within
text in the textbooks these are
textbooks that were adopted in
California and because California is
such a huge market for educational
materials once it's in those textbooks
that's what's disseminated across the
rest of the country it downplays Jihad
it downplays the concept of from The
River To The Sea which is the
eradication of Israel it downplays
Sharia law as something that just means
get closer to God it downplays the
modesty laws and all of that stuff I did
like a I was reading in these textbooks
um it even downplays the uh Islamic
conquest and it says that Islam spread
it doesn't say that Islam not saying
it's spread by the sword it doesn't say
that it's spread by the water it just
naturally to the sword and it also says
like that because that it's part of
Islam that you can't convert people on
purpose and so therefore it's peaceful
and it lives it lives uh Islam lives in
harmony with other religions without
actually mentioning the the horrifying
Wars the like yeah you know all of that
stuff what the cultural implications are
I mean there's a story right now about
this 16-year-old girl yeah we covered
that today at human events yeah she was
uh uh beaten because over she wasn't
wearing her her job correctly I believe
and so she she's in a veget draged from
a train right she's she's in a
vegetative state she I assume will not
make it which is extremely tragic but in
America we get to say like oh it's just
a different culture we don't know what
it's like there it's it's gross we we
would not let this happen here I hope uh
but we do let it happen here I mean we
have there's honor killings in the US
yeah there are but we don't talk about
them yes but while there are many
stories like that there are women being
victimized and beaten in the streets and
men as crime is running rampant we're
now seeing like CVS R Aid Walgreens and
all these stores 1,500 stores are
closing over the over the rampant crime
so when we talk about oh it's so awful
this woman didn't wear her job and he
and she was beaten you're absolutely
right it's horrible and then we have the
story of the woman on the train in
Philadelphia who was raped and everyone
just watched it happen right then you
have the story of the guy in New York
City who saw the dude threatening the
lives of the people on the train and
said I got to stop this guy with three
two other dudes and then they tried to
lock him up yeah they're still trying to
lock him up they're still trying to lock
him up yeah they're we're like we would
never let it happen here and here's a
guy who tried to save the lives of
people on the train and one woman said
that man saved our lives and the Poli
are locking them up in jail so we got
those problems I don't think is that we
don't let bad things happen here it's
just the specific modesty laws don't
exist here the same way except when
they're enforced culturally by we got
the other direction I know this is the
problem I mean it's like we we have the
mirror image to the Iran problem Iran's
problem is they're beating women for not
working a job they shouldn't be doing
that and then and they they kill this
young woman there's protests and then
United States the inverse where they're
putting these LW and lascivious books in
schools and we're like man where's the
middle ground like let women wear you
know sexy clothes but don't give kids
these books with graphic material in and
it's weird because the progressives that
are saying yes put those books in school
are the same ones chanting in favor of
EX right right they would be like the
first ones the wall if phos had anything
to say about they could never survive in
this this culture they're the left tried
arguing this a long time ago that Trump
supporters had a lot in common with like
Al-Qaeda and like Muslim terrorists or
whatever like dude if Hamas did come
over here and it was just like some some
like regular Palestinian guy on a street
corner and he started expressing his
opinions on LGB btq stuff and wokeness a
lot of conservatives would be like I
completely agree with those positions
then of course the guy would say
something like throw him off a roof or
whatever something horrifying and the
Trump support would be like yo bro
what's wrong with you that's crazy
that's like way too far for us but so
many of these leftwing activists are
cheering for a group that as you all
mentioned would either lock them up for
10 years at the law in in Gaza being gay
is a 10-year prison sentence or
something substantially worse yeah I
think I think a lot of them are
definitely uneducated on you know what
goes on in Palestine but I do understand
some of their gripes and I think that
you know you talk about the textbook
things I've heard reports of textbooks
being infiltrated with Zionist uh you
know certain angles and I'm Jewish and
you know I don't want that I want my you
know students in my country learning you
know real truth and you know not you
know that's tampered with by some
special interest and so and I think
that's why a lot of Americans especially
Christian Americans are kind of in TR
with the fact that we must go to war we
must go defend Israel and listen I I
want there to be peace more than anyone
but I don't think we should get involved
with a conflict at all that's foreign I
think we should be focusing on our
issues here like the guy in the subway
and um and I and I just think that
Americans are so funny as at least
Christian Americans and especially those
who call themselves conservatives when
they say let's not go to Ukraine quit
sending my lunch money to Ukraine and
then the second Israel gets attacked
they want to send the kitchen Isel is a
long-standing Ally I and I get that I
get that but when that long-standing
Ally is committing war crimes Israel was
attacked right they were attacked and
that shouldn't have happened and I think
that it's under questionable
circumstances as well because even
Charlie Kirk pointed out that uh when it
happened there was a 7h hour stop order
ordered by Netanyahu he didn't say that
definitively though right which he was
attacked right after too but Charlie
said I wonder if if someone gave a stand
on order cuz how did they not know this
well in in Egypt warned them apparently
too but also Egypt said something big
might happen which is not a warning of
anything it's not it's not we don't we
don't know what the specific
intelligence it was thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net